c'est un dossier de longue date à la
verrière le projet de rénovation du
quartier du bois de l'étang
après s'être engagé durant la campagne
des municipales sur un projet sans
démolition
le maire nicolas dainville a choisi de
suivre une autre option celle de l'
agence nationale de rénovation urbaine
avec une démolition partielle les
financements pourraient atteindre plus
de 60 millions d'euros
d'après les premières estimations on
part sur une inscription dans l'anru
pour avoir le maximum de financement
possibles l'anru passe par quelques
démolition 20 millions d'euros pour
réhabiliter les intérieurs des
appartements les sols les plomberie les
sanitaires les halls les ascenseurs 20
millions d'euros pour les voiries les
espaces verts les aires de jeu 20
millions d'euros pour les équipements
une école une maison de quartier 2
millions d'euros pour sécuriser les
espaces et mieux les délimiter engagé
pendant la campagne sur un projet de
rénovation avec démolition
le conseiller municipal d'opposition
jean yves blé reste sur sa position
on nous annonce de 160 logements
détruits
nous nous étions plutôt sur quelque
chose sur une ligne avec plusieurs
versions de proposer et nous étions sur
la deuxième version autour de 180
logements de son côté nelly duthu ancien
maire de la verrière aujourd'hui
conseillère municipale d'opposition est
toujours en faveur d'un projet de
rénovation sans démolition
elle a interpellé le maire sur le sujet
lors de la séance que l'on soit pour ou
contre les démolitions je dirais c'est
pas le sujet le sujet c'est comment
comment on fait autre chose que ce qu'on
avait dit sans prévenir personne
on peut pas traiter les gens ont peut
pas traiter des habitants de cette façon
si les habitants sont largement
majoritaires pour des démolition de la
bâtisse mais encore faut-il déconcerté
pour le savoir
du côté de certaines associations
l'inquiétude grandit c'est le cas du
collectif des locataires du bois de
l'étang créé en 2014 qui m'a surpris
c'est que ben on n'a aucune visibilité
sur cette chaire de roulement ni sur les
démolitions qui ont été privés
apparemment monsieur david et son équipe
seul mais on fait ce qu'on veut c'est
que ce soit un projet qui soit et c'est
par les habitants avec les habitants
pour les habitants tous les habitants
doivent être consultés pour donner leur
avis s'il ya des démolitions à bail aura
des démissions s'il n'y a pas
d'évolution n'y a pas d'évolution mais
il faut qu'on gagne tous ensemble sur ce
projet comme le maire annonce vouloir
faire une concertation avec les
habitants sur la base de son projet il
prévoit la démolition entre 214 et 264
logements